these people are on a pilgrimage there
in one of the most remote parts of the
United States to see something
spectacular that happens every year an
icon of the American West this is a
sage-grouse and this is its mating dates
the sage-grouse once numbered in the
millions across this entire region but
today they are on the verge of
endangerment in the area they live on
has shrunk by half that's a problem and
not just because it's fun to look at
it's because the sage-grouse is actually
really important and to understand why
you have to understand it's dance this
is a female sage-grouse and this is a
male sage-grouse during mating season
it's big and flamboyant looking also
that it can attract mates
it's sort of like a peacock in that way
the spiky tail the puffed out chest
they don't serve a clear function except
to be attractive these white feathers on
its chest are rough and spiky and for
the first step of its dance the
sage-grouse takes a deep breath and it
swishes its wings against those spiky
feathers it sounds like this these
yellow things are its vocal sac it's
actually one esophagus with a strong
muscle in the center when the
sage-grouse takes in a gulp of air it
contracts when it breathes out the vocal
sac pops that sounds like this female
sage-grouse can hear these sounds from
up to two miles away
and then it's a competition the
strongest male dancers crowd out the
weaker once the winner gets to mate with
most of the females after they mate the
females go up to ten miles away to nest
but this arena where the competition
goes down
that place stays the same every year
sage-grouse live across this whole vast
area but year after year they each come
back to do the courtship ritual in the
same exact spot one of these blue dots
it's why sage-grouse watchers always
know where to find them that mating area
is called a lek and it's a big part of
why sage-grouse matter so much coming
back to the same place every year means
that sage-grouse are really easy to keep
track of some Lexx have been monitored
by researchers for more than 75 years
they are so easy to count that
conservationists consider them an
indicator species that means they use
the number of sage-grouse as a sort of
proxy for how healthy the entire
sagebrush ecosystem is if sage grafts
are doing well there's a good chance
that elk and pygmy rabbits and the 350
plant and animal species in the region
are doing okay - that also means that if
you want to protect wildlife in the
American West
figuring out how to protect the
sage-grouse is a good strategy in 2008
Wyoming implemented a new policy aimed
at protecting the bird it ended up also
having major benefits for another animal
the mule deer but because sage-grouse
are so easy to count we also know that
they are in trouble the lek is where the
sage-grouse mates but it's just the
epicenter of a much larger range where
they live and in order for them to keep
coming back to the lek to reproduce
sage-grouse need the entire range to be
undisturbed
that means if human activity alters this
range they tend to not return to the lek
they don't reproduce Montana started
keeping track of sage-grouse Lacs in
2002 since then their population in the
state has fallen by nearly half
there are a lot of reasons for this
decline invasive plant species wildfires
but a big one is drilling and mining
western states of increased production
dramatically in recent years
a huge amount of new oil oil coal and
natural gas dominates the landscape and
the economy Wyoming has the most sage
grouse of any state here's a map of Lex
in Wyoming and these are oil and gas
fields in 2015
governor's from four states announced a
plan with the federal government to
protect the sage-grouse it banned
mineral mining across ten million acres
of sage-grouse habitat and it restricted
oil and gas leasing and 13,000 square
miles of the most critical habitat areas
it was hailed as the largest
conservation effort in US history but
today Donald Trump's administration
isn't enforcing the restrictions on oil
and gas leasing and it cancelled the ban
on mining here and the numbers reflect
that since he took office oil and gas
leasing on public land in the US has
skyrocketed and on land the 2015 plan
was supposed to protect leasing has gone
up tenfold
today officials predict that sage-grouse
numbers will keep falling
the sage-grouse is an indicator species
it means that the sage-grouse can tell
you a lot about the health of the entire
sagebrush ecosystem across the American
West but they can also indicate
something about American policy about
the power that fossil fuel and mining
companies have over government about
what we choose to protect and what we
don't
[Music]